buenas tardes el presidente pedro
castillo lleva más de 40 minutos
hablando en el parlamento peruano el
mandatario ha sido enfático en señalar
que las burlas y los insultos de la
oposición no lo van a hacer retroceder
en ese sentido pedro castillo ha
manifestado que se va a someter a la
investigación de la justicia para
esclarecer todas las acusaciones de
delitos que se les están incriminando en
este momento castillo también ha sido
muy claro al advertir a los medios de
comunicación que según él están
emitiendo noticias e informaciones
falsas y dice que en las acusaciones por
corrupción que emiten los medios a
diario no van a poder ser probadas
porque pruebas no las hay el mandatario
también ha señalado en su discurso que
va a hacer un programa para otorgar
viviendas a la población vulnerable en
otros sentidos también ha prometido
destinar 30 millones de dólares para
defender a la población vulnerable con
esta situación que está viviendo el país
con el alza de alimentos en otros
aspectos económicos el mandato ha
prometido la masificación del gas
natural a los hogares del perú y también
ha señalado que la empresa nacional de
hidrocarburos
petroperú va a comenzar la va a volver
mejor dicho a la explotación del
petróleo y cómo es el ambiente dentro
del hemiciclo que se ha visto allí como
recibe la oposición el discurso del
presidente
bueno contarle que en las calles hay
manifestaciones unos que están a favor
de pedro castillo y que exigen que se
cierre el congreso y otros que están en
contra del mandatario y le están
pidiendo la renuncia porque están
cansados de que y lo acusan al
mandatario de no haber cumplido sus
promesas de campaña al interior del
hemiciclo podemos destacar que hay
algunos congresistas que le han dado la
espalda al mandatario desde como desde
que comenzó a hablar y hay tres
legisladores que abandonaron el
hemiciclo en señal de protesta y uno de
ellos se fue retirando del parlamento
insultando a pedro casio mientras estaba
hablando a los peruanos y hemos hablado
de las polémicas que rodean a pedro
castillo después de este año de gobierno
cuéntanos resumidamente los últimos
reveses para el presidente
el principal es que la fiscalía de la
nación lo ha acusado de dirigir
supuestamente a una organización
criminal el ministerio público ha
abierto cinco investigaciones en las
cuales las principales denuncias son por
corrupción peculado tráfico de
influencias y obstrucción a la justicia
en este punto su principal
colaborador su ex secretario bruno
pacheco se entregó a la fiscalía y lo
acusó de cobrar 20 mil dólares en los
ascensos a generales de la policía en la
verdad que la situación se le pone muy
complicada a pedro que ha sido porque el
abogado del ex ministro de transporte
juan silva ha señalado que él también se
va a entregar con estos dos testimonios
están diciendo muchos juristas que pedro
casi o va a tener la situación mucho más
complicada y su situación en la
presidencia correría peligro